[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
stéphane olivié bisson pour douce france
une pièce de théâtre au tristan-bernard
qui nous racontent tous les présidents
de la vème république
fixi du groupe java dont la tournée dans
toute la france se terminera le 7
décembre à paris à l'elysée montmartre
hélios azoulay pour son roman juste
avant d'éteindre et on commence tout de
suite pas l'image que vous avez choisie
pour illustrer notre époque stéphane
olivié bisson cette image là voici je
reconnais le drapeau libanais mais de
quoi s'agit-il s'agit de la crise
actuelle au liban j'ai beaucoup
travaillé au liban j'ai beaucoup d'amis
là bas j'avais monté 80 chatila de jean
genet en théâtre monnot un pérou depuis
dans tout le moyen-orient
c'est la caricature
effroyable de ce que je redoute qui
puisse arriver un jour à notre pays
peut-être je ne souhaite pas
d'une un pouvoir confisqué par une
oligarchie ultra financière et mafieuses
et d'un peuple à la porte de son propre
destin quoi voilà eh bien parlons de
parlons de cette pièce 12 france vous
l'avez coécrite avec et vous l'a commise
et mettez en scène et vous l'interprétez
avec david salle c'est trop tous à un
autre
c'est donc au théâtre tristan bernard
douce france ça se passe à l'elysée où
deux conseillers hors d'âge nous voulons
revivre les grands moments de la vème
république du général de gaulle à
emmanuel macron enfin quand je dis les
grands moments pour dire les pires
moments car vous n'avez pas beaucoup la
vème république je me dis c'est un peu
l'histoire de france des 60 dernières
années revue par l'egypte allait gilet
jaune oh non non c'est pas par enfant de
la cinquième en tout cas ce que j'avais
vu les jets régionaux si oui oui enfin
je sais pas ça dépend de leur âge mais
moi j'ai ouï gp quoi je finis en février
69 donc je crois que référendum c'est en
mars il me semble dans 69 camp de gaulle
par
non j'ai juste fait 50 52 ans que je vis
je n'ai toujours rien compris à ce
régime jeu on parle de monarchie
républicaine oui enfin je sais pas je me
souviens de s'était engueulé merkel qui
étaient dans la voiture que avec chirac
revenant de l'aéroport et puis
ils font quelques kilomètres et puis
s'arrête et et chirac unis me voici
l'escort on va aller à l'elysée avec les
scores on n'était pas en voit tous non
mais il faut une escorte mais si je fais
ça à berlin je me fait lyncher dans la
seconde enfin non c'est un drôle drôle
de régime auquel je comprends pas grand
chose je vous avoue il m'a passionné
depuis l'adolescence je ne sais pas
pourquoi je la politique me fascine
après c'est pas que les ados mines m
c'est pas que les personnes
oui c'est le général de gaulle quand
même oui par exemple dont on a tous la
religion aujourd'hui la soirée son
départ et bien vous en parler un peu
d'âme narc bon ben ça n'aide pas à louer
en uniforme de la seconde guerre
mondiale et qui lancent des fusées qui
fait péter des bombes atomiques
qui recolonise l'afrique grâce et la
coopération
voilà ce que vous retenez du général de
gaulle là j'ai connu je pense pas le
meilleur moi j'ai connu la faim le bout
du bout du général de gaulle
après
j'ai grandi effectivement dans la
religion de ce saint laïc construit
bizarrement jeu quand on se penche un
tantinet sur l'histoire il ya des faces
d'une noirceur infinie vous pensez
vraiment qu'il a perdu les pédales en
mai 68 au point au point de penser à
faire sauter les parachutistes sur la
question après je ne sais pas s'il
serait allé jusque là mais je d'après
certains rapports de certains de ses
ministres qui ont parlé après il était
pour la manière forte très tôt d'après
ce que j'ai compris
et cj m'ont dit oui c'est ce qu'ont dit
les pompidou l'aurait modéré d'autres
ministres modérés etc et
puis oui le départ à baden baden et très
étrange qu'il n'y a rien il ya un côté
diva blessé qui est curieux quoi et ce
n'est pas la première fois dans ta jeune
carrière
oui c'est ça il dramatise quand en 46
quand il part il va pas il va pas en
allemagne n'ont pas ce coup là en soi ce
soir était très voyant peut-être à
l'époque c'était trop tôt georges
pompidou voulez mais encore moins alors
lui céder pas l'armée son truc c'est les
bagnoles oui il veut en mettre partout
oui oui mais là ce projet d'autoroute en
plein centre ville où il faudrait raser
le quartier historique du marais j'ai vu
les images du projet de le corbusier de
cet effarant
c'est le projet de le corbusier est ce
que c'était vraiment rejette pompidou a
rarement il était oui il était
accompagné par genre de périphérique les
voies express
ouais ouais je pense qu'on a un peu
j'ai bien peur que l'on est on est des
morts précoces dans ma génération parce
que puisqu'on a mangé
sous pompidou et sous giscard enfin des
pommes qui faisait comme ça
non pompidou après c'est le sait c'est
un personnage que kick pour lequel j'ai
quand même une tendresse par sa culture
sont enfin son élan pour pour les arts
après il ya une espèce de volontarisme
moderniste naïf parce que les les
je pense au salon paulin par exemple à
l'elysée qu'ils ont gardé que j'ai vu
voilà je pensais d'un modernisme
extrêmement date est celle de 48 heures
mais
il était au delà du bagad c'est
artistiquement était dans la vallée mais
l'avant garde oui oui et de belles âmes
en garde compères durée mais il ya une
espèce de volontarisme formelle curieux
mais je n'ai pas le les quais de seine
pompidolien là c'est ce qu'il ya quand
même de plus moche à paris quoi oui
enfin c'était bien pratique parti ce
matin alors vous en vous en profiter
dans cette pièce pour nous rappeler une
des pages les plus sombres de notre
histoire c'est qu'en 1972 année rêver de
tous les français puisque la nostalgie
française se porte et anciennement en
1972 on l'a vu on venait me retourne en
1972 en 1972 7 millions de français sont
allés au cinéma pour voir les bidasses
en folie dont dieu oui sans doute l'un
des plus grands avec will et j'avais
fait dit regardable aujourd'hui hommage
à l'histoire voilà c'était absolument
épouvantable je dis ça je vais même
jamais vu mais c'est vrai j'ai refusé
l'offre
ça sentait le navet la bêtise et ses 7
millions de gens sont allés voir 7
millions j'ignorais le chiffre un
monstre sème et lyon c'est ça de mes
premiers souvenirs de cinéma voilà
j'aime beaucoup le cinéma malgré ça mais
c'est oui ça est effroyablement marquant
j'ai tenté de le revoir il ya six mois
quand on a dansé direct david qu'ont-ils
mettre dans le spectacle j'ai tenu dix
minutes tendance est impossible
oui là aussi il ya une volonté de de
rieux quentin contre 17 me de profits
d'autres y était pour rien non je pense
pas qu'ils soient n'ont évidemment ni
absente ce complot
contre le rire
et les giscard d'estaing oui
venez giscard d'estaing oui qu'est ce
qu'on peut lui reprocher il était
bonheur de lui non lui ou vraiment qu'il
ya des réformes importantes enfin voila
c'est quelqu'un pour lequel je reconnais
une année et demi de réformes sur
lesquelles on on vit encore et qui sont
décisives mais alors après non toute
l'histoire de la particule le rêve qu'il
fait de lui-même en descendant de louis
villas chasse l'achat bah oui c'est sûr
c'est un spectacle oui oui enfin
les conseillers qui nous raconte ouais
ce qu'ils ont vécu à l'elysée nous parle
surtout de la chasse c'est vrai oui il
ya un mois j'ai rencontré des gens qui
étaient qu'ils étaient adolescents au
moment des battues en bourgogne et
qu'ils étaient dans les espèces de
fossés où il recevait les faisans lâchés
à cinq mètres en
tombereaux et qu'ils entendaient les
chasseurs qui accompagnait ses chasselas
et de dire c'est pas un chasseur c'est
un viandard n'est pas des nôtres un bon
bref quelque chose mais
oui non non se base pour pour moi un
espèce de l'incarnation suprême de
la monarchie républicaine sont debout et
le problème quoi puis aux six mois il
met tous ma faim je sais qu est ce qui
vous a donné envie d'écrire un spectacle
comme celui ci dans le voir là toute la
vème république à travers les souvenirs
de deux conseillers qui serait là depuis
huit jours de pluie napoléon iii le
premier depuis quarante-huit quoi wissam
ça m'amusait non ce qui m'intéressait
c'était de basculer dans la
documentation d'aller chercher le vrai
je me disais ne
sera jamais le vrai plutôt avec d'othe
que vous racontez elles ont été
racontées ici ou là mais est ce que
c'est vrai j'ai fait beaucoup retrouver
à droite à gauche et essayer de perdre
et celles qui étaient les plus partagés
on répète beaucoup ce qu'on a lu
ailleurs bon je suis pas verser dans des
sources douteuses j'ai essayé de
m'attacher à des livres plutôt
d'histoire il ne s'est pas des livres de
rumeurs ou d'anecdotes mais ce qui
m'intéressait c'était surtout de pape a
proposé une une
pas de tordre le bras aux gens pour leur
dire ce qu'il faut penser qu'elle serait
maddox
et on on sent dans dans la salle plus on
laisse la place pour ça le choix de ses
personnages il y en a un qui est plutôt
de gauche un peu honteux à des deux
continents castriste et puis bon après
c'est dans le rang le mien
curiosité pierre marie josèphe une
église à lui tout seul point il est oui
tradi droite 1 mais bon pas tant
affichée que ça
ce qui nous ce qui nous amusent s était
de fait c'est venu vraiment d'un ami qui
est dir cab dont je ne peux pas dire le
nom et qui m'a dit nous sommes les
trains ils sont la gare s'est passé dans
ce spectacle c'est cette phrase là qu'à
actionner le désir de faire ça il vous
faut les directeurs de cabinet les
administrations c'est la gare actuelle
l'état profond ça
m'a dit écoute si on a envie de freiner
si on a envie de court circuiter si on a
envie de gagner du temps quel que soit
l'impulsion mêmes l'énergie de
l'impulsion au centre on peut le faire
ça m'a beaucoup intrigué je me dis tiens
et si on regardait on traversait ses 55
années travers le regard de ces deux
clampins qui n'ont pas d'autres pouvoirs
que deux des de défendre l'indéfendable
puisque sont payés pour ça alors
mitterrand bon c'est la gauche au
pouvoir mais ça ça n'a duré que deux ans
de vous
le dire voilà et sinon c'est un peu ce
sera un peu notre nixon en fait à nous
écouter les fruits que les coups tordus
s'est il fait sauter le bateau de
greenpeace
il ad des tas de secrets qu'il faut
surtout pas divulgué et en plus il se
fait réélire triomphalement avec pas de
programme comme comme dixon nixon
d'activer triomphal - oui oui oui mais
j'ai pas compris la réélection de j'ai
voté c'était ma première fois que je
faisais c'était en 88 g beauté damman
d'emblée pour pour lui à mai mais plus
il y avait une cohabitation avant oui
oui j'aurais dans les manifs voilà de 86
malik oussékine et tout ça donc mais je
pense que j'ai voté par nostalgie d'une
chose que je vais pas bien connu qui
étaient 80 donc c'est vraiment que voter
naïvement et politiquement mais je
pourrais pas vous dire quelle était la
proposition de programme de 88 pour ces
jeux là par la lettre aux français je ne
vois pas je cherchais je ne me vois pas
mais peut-être votre contre en fait on a
voté contre chirac c'est maintenant le
mettre en premier ministre plutôt que
pour mitterrand et c'est un grand barça
je ne sais pas c'est la démocratie
visible non mais de votre les contraint
à voter par adhésion ça fait longtemps
que mais
oui oui oui macé mais là maintenant je
ne sais pas alors où nous sommes je ne
sais même plus si je vais réussir à
voter contre
il ya évidemment jacques chirac jacques
chirac c'est la trahison permanente
d'après vous il ya t'il politique ce
pôle sol il a trahi ses idées il a trahi
tous ses mentors tout ce qu'il en fait
grimper il a trahi ses électeurs
et puis s'est trahi lui même parce
qu'ils n'arrêtent pas de mentir avouez
que vous dites en tout cas ce que disent
ce que dit oui puis de suture la légende
est ainsi tombé qui ont l'air de la
citation de mitterrand qui était
litigieuse il dit
et pourtant je me connais
jamais de ma vie je n'ai vu un homme
mentir à ce point chirac mans tout le
temps en fait on peut même pas croire le
contraire de ce qu'il dit
après mais ce qui m'a fasciné chez
chirac c'était la dernière image d'un
documentaire de patrick rotman ou ou sté
une image l'interview années 70 je pense
et l'intervieweuse lui dit mais lui
demande mais ce que vous aimez au fond
et l'a blanchi il est perdu c'est un
enfant et d'y couper et j'ai trouvé ça
bouleversant mais ils savent mais
sûrement pas jacques chirac en tout cas
les livres d'histoire qui comme à
poindre ont l'air de dire qu'il ne sait
mais pas beaucoup je savais qu'il était
passé sous ça qui m'a fasciné dans ce
parcours c'est pour ça que j'en parlais
dorny temps une politique sérieuse oui
c'est de cette personne j'ai
l'impression a couru après elle même
pendant des décennies ça me fascine oui
mais alors comment expliquez vous qu'il
est qu'il est dur et à la fois comme
maire de paris comme chef de la droite
et et comme président de la république
nan je ris parce qu'il a une phrase lui
même il dit les gens intelligents une à
5 ou 6% moi je fais campagne auprès des
cons je suis désolé c'est pas une vraie
réponse à votre question mais ça m'est
revenue tout
nicolas sarkozy alors là c'est la fin de
la syntaxe bah oui ça c'est une caillera
l elysée c'est ça c'est la fin d'un
monde je le dis pas mais vous le dit et
le non non je sais c'est la joie de vous
donner oui c'est ça et encore vous
verrez jouer terrible encore pire mais
où est passée la vulgarité absolue le le
nombril triomphant mais assumer le côté
est ce que vous trouvez toutes ses
phrases à l'époque comment cette part
est ce que vous trouvez normal que s'il
y avait une évidence derrière ben oui
forcément et puis se le dise ça aurait
pu être un grand président quand même
même vulgaire même même
sacrifiant la syntaxe est ce qu il avait
un dessin je peux a l'impression son
programme à part lui même j'ai pas vu je
pars
quand moi je suis assez d'accord que la
phase de mitterrand pour le coup qui
disait après je suis le dernier des
grands présidents après moi il y aura
des financiers des comptables par lui
c'est plus un représentant de home salon
mais
un vendeur de bagnoles mais je ne sais
pas j'ai
françois hollande oui alors lui c'est
bastos hollande c'est le président des
bisous il a dit lui même il a il a dit
un enfant dans une visite à une école
jeu tu sais je ferai le président des
bisous voilà quelques semaines après
avoir été lu et sinon c'est rain man
payés qu'ils soient man il faut dire on
a cherché de photos on n'a pas eu de mal
à en trouver ses marques c'est la borne
beaucoup sur françois hollande la pluie
sans cesse sur france ô et c'est bizarre
d'ailleurs parce que au fond c'est
peut-être ce qu'il restera de lui
tellement aujourd'hui personne ne lui
accordent le moins le moindre acte
positif
j'ai pas de nicolas sarkozy on se dit
quand même pendant la crise des
subprimes l'union pour la méditerranée
c'était quand même quelque chose enfin
plein de choses que ouais ou ont fini
par accorder au crédit de vidic sarkozy
françois lors rien pour l'attaquant mais
peut-être trop tôt quand même pendant
pendant les attentats je trouve qu'il a
une stature il applaudi lors de leur
nationalité les danses à ses origines
voient la femme mais je veux dire les
jours donc ça s'est passé oui il était
digne quoi oui non jour un plus haut de
dix mois qu'il était le royaume uni est
plutôt dinoire une palette mais à non
après il ya je me souviens cette chose
au mali quand il y quand il dit cette
phrase qui pour moi un symptôme de la
psyché de ces gens
c'est devant la foule la foule soulagé
de ne pas avoir été massacrées par
d'autres c'est le plus beau jour de ma
vie politique alors ça j'avoue je suis
tombé de l'armoire
faudra qu'on m'explique qu'ils s'étaient
sortis utile mais de ma vie politique
voyez le truc c'est ça qui m'embête
assez qu'ils aient pensé à lui oui puis
à lui s'inscrivant dans une destinée qui
s'est promis à lui-même fin voyais
espèce de
d'enfermement narcissique effroyable au
mali un jeune devant des gens
c'est peut-être difficile quand on est
président de la république de la vème
république je me dois de ne pas être de
lego le narcissisme mais c'est ce qu'on
met dans le sous titre du spectacle csi
vous puisqu'on en parle d'eux mais si
vous vous moi qui que ce soit on nous
plongeait dans ce bain là je pense qu'au
bout de six mois on les fout
irrécupérable ces deux mois c'est le
régime qui m'intéresse c'est pour ça
c'est parce que des attaques ad hominem
c'est une chronique c'est une fantaisie
satie satirique mais mais à la fin ce
qu'on met à la fin du spectacle c'est le
blason la 5e mais c'est pas un portrait
c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait est que ce
monstre mais moi ce qui m'étonne
d'autant plus c'est pourquoi il y en a
tant qui veulent être président de la
république
d'abord parce qu'ils savent que ils vont
être détesté méprisé qui vont finir
épinglé dans un spectacle comme celui ci
au fond entre vous n'êtes pas le premier
à l'honneur du mal et vous ne serez pas
le dernier non et mais voilà du temps de
de gaulle de de pompidou il avait
vraiment du pouvoir oui aujourd'hui en
plus ils en ont de moins en moins et
qui isolait devient plus rentable pour
les déteste il ya même plus d'état de
grâce en face à durrrr samia jusque
jeudi à propos de hollande il a duré dix
minutes on est et on les déteste tout de
suite type pourquoi est ce qu'ils
veulent c'est aussi nombreux à vouloir
président de la république mais je pense
que ma sais pas draguer à payer non je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on peut appeler ça
une maladie mentale
nous pensons d'une pathologie quoi une
pathologie narcissique grave
m'amuse mais oui est ce que je t'ai
manuel macron par exemple il aurait pu
faire une belle carrière il a préféré
président de la république et il a il va
vraisemblablement se représenter il ya
de bonnes chances qu'il soit réélu vous
l'expliquer ça peut pas tout expliquer
par juste une fêlure mentale non non non
non non non non emmanuel macron pour moi
il va au delà de la personne pour moi il
ya une c'est ce qu'on se concentre dans
ce spectacle espèces d'accélération sur
du vide
de furia
agité une espèce de concentrer et de
citations de tous les autres mandats
parce que j'ai cru comprendre qu'il
avait une personne qui était chargée
à l'elysée d'aller chercher des
événements symboliques des choses qui
ont marqué les quinquennat le septennat
président précédent pour les cités dans
l'espèce de grand mix synth pop dj
politique et ouais je l'impression qu'il
peut être qu'il règle est philosophe
qu'il doit être écrivain king
beaucoup de choses me financiers etc etc
il est tout en même temps je lance qui
m'effare c'est le l'absence déclaré et
assumée dans enfin de d'affect le dit
lui-même ça je trouve ça incroyable
qu'on puisse maintenant l'assumé tout en
se présentant devant une multitude
non je là je comprends encore moins
qu'avant avant il y avait fait pas des
figures du destin ce qui n'a pas eu de
chance en russie s'est pris à la fois le
mouvement des gilets jaunes et le
coronel virus mais ce que c'était une
fatalité ou ce qu'il appelle un peu
provoc et je pars pas du coronavirus 1
je suis pas ses points
mais ce que parce bas il ya des crises
tu trouves qu'il a quand même suscité
qu'enfin une succession une cascade de
crise dans un temps regroupée qui est
impressionnante vous vous êtes bien
conscient que quand on va voir ce genre
de spectacle on a encore moins envie de
voter or j'en fais personnellement pas
une religion mais maintenant mais
beaucoup de gens pensent qu'il faut
inciter au contraire ouais mais ça les
gens à voter c'est mon problème c'est
que c'est pas ça que je cherche c'est
bien que les gens aillent voter mais
c'est pas ce spectacle ou jadot cause
j'ai passé c'est non c'est juste au
contraire voilà ce qui s'est passé ce
qu'on a peut-être oublié il ya une
phrase dans le spectacle c'est si les
français avaient de la mémoire il
répugne hommes politiques en activité
c'est juste un exercice de mémoire
mais pour ceux proposés à nous-mêmes
autres peut-être autre chose mais vous
incriminez la mémoire mais on a une
mémoire sélective on se souvient
toujours de la même chose elle a
beaucoup beaucoup d'anecdotes
d'allusions vous faites dans ce
spectacle à des allusions à des choses
que l'on sait déjà
en revanche il ya plein de choses qu'on
a oublié juste tellement concernant
georges pompidou si nicolas sarkozy je
vais aller de l'union pour la
méditerranée pour une personne ne se
souvient de l'union pour le bénin carnet
alors que c'est une grande victoire
diplomatique pour nicolas sarkozy
souvient tous de kadhafi ouais dans les
jardins de marigny avec vos attentes
mais on se souvient pas de l'union pour
la méditerranée et donc on a une mémoire
sélective oui vous y participer
j'espère qu'elle n'amène incline pas
dans ceux dans le cliché la caricature
de nom mais c'est lourd ou quoi c'est
toujours les mêmes ces événements dont
on se souvient ben moi il est chaud oui
oui oui mais après il ya des choses
qu'on propose dans le spectacle que
j'ignorais avant même de me pencher oui
j'avais découvert les craintes
totalement les bidasses en folie non ça
c'était trop sagement soumettre ou sa
non des choses oui effarante enfin le
bon ça mais ça c'est du pur gag mais je
ne l'aurais jamais eu l'imagination
d'inventer un gag taille l'histoire de
l'ours déchets ou chez scoop un gant
mais c'est vrai ça et oui c'est vrai
mais je ne trouvais si la fois des
applis dame de grâce côtés lobs des
spectateurs puisque vous en prenez la
raison j'en prends la responsabilité
donc
jusqu'à se rendre en roumanie et puis il
veut chasser veut chasser on dit que
vous voulez chasser je chassais l'ours
alors alors il y aller chercher school
et 10 très bien mais on va vous prêter
les leviers ce mot prêté un ours du zoo
de bucarest donc pour vous re ce qui
était paisiblement avec vous croyez
chirac giscard qui est un chasseur à
vrai chasseur qu'on aime ou qu'on n'aime
pas oui il va tirer sur un zoo qu'on a
vient de libérer du lorsqu'on vient de
libérer du joug ils ignoraient à holly
l'ours était dans les soutes de l'avion
présidentiel ils l'ont débarquer dans
les
raconter non non non non non non c'est
d'autres gens qui racontent que wise as
et ils l'ont libéré ne requiert pas de
conseil dans une grotte en fumée l'one
et ils étaient à cinq mètres la défense
et
la semaine d'après et on le met ça ou
sinon spectacle la semaine d'après il il
est invité à 30 millions d'amis pour
parler de la souffrance animale et sa
fille
eto'o
c'est un crétin je n'ai plus à l'école
de vétérinaires voilà deux vétérinaires
et sera nommé discrétionnairement
étrangement
directrice adjointe d'un zoo à pékin
c'est incompatible les chasseurs aime
vivre près des animaux tels comme les
vétérinaires et
j'aime bien ça
y'a un rapport à l'animal au fond qui
est par rapport à l'animal particulier
vous venez de créer cette pièce qui sont
les gens qui viennent la voir tu as
encore jeu c'est un parce que dans mon
esprit ce que les donc je me disais
parce qu'il ya énormément d'allusions à
des choses que la plupart des gens qui
ont moins de 25 ans par exemple ont
totalement bleu ou non n'a jamais eu
même l'idée et il y avait par exemple à
la première il y avait des voisins de
l'actrice delphine baril keith qui ont
entre 19 et 21 ans donc ils étaient une
dizaine ils sont venus et j'ai parlé
avec eux après auxerre et il me disait
que pour eux c'était des noms du manuel
d'histoire et qu'ils imaginent n'est pas
une seconde qu'ils un qu'ils aient plus
qu'ils aient pu durer autant
mais si c'est à dire du autant 17 ans il
n'en revenait pas du septennat
prenez pas cette menace est pour eux
s'étaient alors mis sur lui on a fait 2
vous imaginez oui oui mais non c'était
bien n'y avait pas il y avait une espèce
de curiosité
assez amusé pour ces étranges animaux
quoi bon l'annoncé tête nous ils
s'étaient pas qu'elle puisse que nous
dise ce que nous disent pour l'instant
depuis les monts a joué trois fois jeudi
vendredi samedi pourtant débarquons et
maintenant ils nous disent au fond c'est
pas de la ses pattes la sphère politique
c'est nos vies c'est des madeleines ce
qu on a trahi qu il na il ya beaucoup de
documents enfin beaucoup de gens n'a pas
trop pas que ça distrait trop du plateau
mais il y en a donc été des vidéos des
archives il ya une archive délicieuse du
général de gaulle pour les voeux de 1967
ont vu de l'année 68 ou is it baudelaire
je crois la vie et la simple et
tranquille et elie je forme le voeu le
plus serein pour l'année qui vient enfin
de
suppositoire exquis
il annonce une année 68 tranquille c'est
ça totalement cotonneuse
mais voilà puis on a demandé des photos
parce qu'il y ait des il ya des figures
compte
pour beaucoup de gens qui ont disparu
totalement et puis des figures
contenteront souvient mais dont on se
souvient pas exactement de l'aspect un
certain moment de leur vie j'ai une
magnifique photo de de charles pasqua
sur un chantier avec des lunettes noires
et un verre de riz 15 à l'époque où il
était encore ministre ni même ne mange
le
oui au moment juste au juste avant qu'il
y n'y que yes est cette élection à
neuilly si curieuse mais au fond c'est
une façon de raconter un peu votre vie à
vous puisque vous aussi 1969 oui et et
vous apercevoir que vous faites ça fait
longtemps que vous êtes là déjà
annoncé la patronne actuelle oui oui non
non mais c'est vrai il c'est vrai qu'il
ya une v6 mot
autobiographique douce france c'est donc
au théâtre tristan bernard tous les
soirs avec david salle qui accueillait
des ailes et delphine baril de feedback
merci stéphane olivié merci à vous on
fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après avec fixie l'un des fondateurs du
groupe java
[Musique]
fixi vous êtes
accordéoniste et l'un des fondateurs du
groupe java qui s'est reformé pour son
vingtième anniversaire
après 10 ans de séparation et dont la
tournée dans toute la france s'achèvera
le 7 décembre à paris à l'elysée
montmartre alors voici l'image que vous
avez choisi pour symboliser
l'époque sur des abeilles c'est ma c'est
une de mes ruches
non je voulais je voulais qu'on mettre
un petit éclairage sur les abeilles
c'est un peu une déclaration d'amour
aussi parce que je les aime et je pense
que c'est un bien commun
de notre notaire et que depuis des
décennies la leçon pas mal martyrisé et
là je trouve que la beille c'est un beau
symbole aussi de de ceux de ce rapport
entre l'homme et la nature parce que la
bei un peu entre tout ça et sans elle on
sait bien que la pollinisation
disparaîtrait donc tel point qu'aux
états unis il charge des ruches sur des
camions pour les faire voyager de d'état
en état parce qu'il ya des terrains où
les plus d'abeilles assez nombreuses
pour à polliniser et voilà donc et moi
j'ai la chance de d'avoir ce rapport
avec les abeilles de l'est de les faire
travailler et les exploités ou les
exploiter mais en bonne en bonne entente
je leur fais de la musique aussi temps
en temps
et enfin je les respecte le mieux que je
peux mais en tout cas je vois j'ai les
mains dans du miel et je les observe et
je vois certaines années les souffrances
qu'elles peuvent avoir leur il ya plein
de types de maladies mais il ya aussi ce
que l'homme lui fait subir et avec les
pesticides qui entoure mais ma région
c'est une région assez productiviste en
agricole donc voilà il ya des menaces et
et ça c'est un lien voilà c'est assez
clair avec notre environnement qui se
dégrader et notre notre vieux
compagnonnage avec les abeilles le tout
premier album du groupe java hawaï date
de l'an 2000 il vient de ressortir en cd
et en vinyle avec quatre titres en bonus
vous étiez les premiers à l'époque à
mélanger le rap et l'accordéon musette
vous était venu comment l'idée vois ça
c'est plusieurs choses c'est je pense un
espace de
de résistance
- de tendance française musicale qui est
souvent de copier ce qui se fait à
l'extérieur mais un peu copié collé on
va dire comme le rock comme comme le hip
hop dans les années 90
le jazz aussi une certaine manière enfin
je pense un peu tous les styles de
musique toutes les époques et
je trouve qu'en france on se pose pas
c'est la question de voilà qui je suis
où je vais comment avec quoi et
qu'est-ce qui venait avant moi qu'est-ce
que je vais projeté devant moi et donc
on la leur le hip hop commence à être
très très puissant en france parce qu'on
est d'abord des découvreurs aussi de
talent puisqu'on et des curieux et donc
on s'est nourri de ce qui se passe aux
etats-unis très bien génial mais après
pour la caisse qu'est ce qu'on a créé
nous et et puis en regardant un peu ça
de plus près
et aussi un groupe très important pour
moi à cette époque-là américain qui
s'appelait the roots et d'un groupe de
hip hop mais qui mangeaient qui
mélangent et l'acoustique dont
contrebasse vraie batterie parfois
fender rhodes et moi qui vient beaucoup
du jazz j'étais très sensible à cette
approche où déjà ça m'a ouvert
une fenêtre sur la possibilité de faire
du rap avec des vrais instruments et
ensuite je me suis dit bon balle et les
américains il sample des vieux vinyles
de jazz de soul music peut-être que nous
on aurait dans notre entre armoires
quelques disques à son play donc du coup
de là est venue mama recherche des vieux
morceaux d'accordéon ondes et de
découvrir en fait le monde enfin notre
époque et l époque entre deux guerres et
juste après guerre aussi avec toute une
panoplie d'immenses artistes français
souvent d'origine italienne enfin d'un
peu partout j'ai gitans et serra qui ont
créé le genre musette avec la java le
foxtrot tous ces rythmes l'a compris on
va regarder un extrait de du clip de
cendriers
2003 cendrier
le groupe java dans le cendrier
il était une fois
sans payer il avait écopé ce blaze un
jour vu qu'il était encore plus
tabagique que gainsbourg mais surnom il
avait jamais aussi bien porté ce matin
là sont dix mètres carrés empestait
l'alcool et le tabac froid l'odeur de
cadavres le dirach du sommeil pour leur
plongée aussi sacs dans ses exploits de
la veille rmiste de vocation ces deux
demi frères ne manquait jamais de lui
rappeler sa position sociale voulait
bien laisser cette chambre de bonne au
dernier étage mais en échange tous les
jours dans leur loft qui fait faire le
ménage faut dire que ces deux là étaient
pleins aux as elle a été créée à dans la
pub y avait une audi tt de glace l'autre
était plus révoltés critique de musique
aux inrockuptibles il adorait la pop un
12-2 lander grande sans landais bref il
aurait prise est il n'arrêtait pas de le
narguer parce qu'ils avaient un carton
spécial bp pour la grande soirée donné
le soir même et par le comte dardy
sniffer puisses tu es encore à vis
d'elle tard alors riga avec la halle aux
toiles hier une façon qui aurait voulu
que ce dg s'est pris dans ses pensées
qu'ils impriment hors du lit il était 5
heures de l'après midi
[Musique]
le capitaine caverne marchand radar pour
atteindre les chiottes mis un pied dans
standard aird qu'yat-il la seconde se
répandit dans les airs à ce moment
arriver à quelque chose d'extraordinaire
dans un nuage de cendres a paru la fiche
thann elle était belle jeune elle
sentait le mégot chaud mais dit sa voix
éraillée on veut ce soir pour aller
danser en merci je transforme tout ce
que je touche à gauche je dois faire
mais je pensais plèbe et ouamane fanta
rouches turfoo du boulot à temps de la
baguette castagnettes je te faire ne
soyez rebaï djabou ce soir tu seras un
bar-tabac delà c'est un costard poteau
madère n'a pas de site web banon qui va
regarder le paquet sur le banc quand
même super pour la soirée jet set la
tension les conditions de sherry cooper
est plus folle que la nuit tout le monde
ce sont les premières lueurs mais tant
pis pour la terre
ap
pourquoi ces six français l'accordéon
c'est pas nous qui l'avons inventé non
parce que ces deux feux chlore je
pensais à une association avec paris
l'après guerre avec edith piaf
mais c'est une bonne question parce que
moi j'ai beaucoup voyagé la chance de
voyager énormément au brésil l'accordéon
est roi oui avec l'avionneur oui voilà
la lega ce cas pourquoi la france s'est
associée bahia le fromage la baguette et
l'accordéon je ne les ai pas c'est il
verrait peut-être un peu la casquette le
béret plus tôt j'avais s'est fait
connaître par les concerts à l'époque
ouais c'est vrai enfin il y avait un peu
tourné à
la radio qui nous aimait bien aussi mais
on a on a fait nos preuves en concert et
avec quelque chose d'assez
imprévisible avec java qui est toujours
le cas d'ailleurs par moments on a
essayé d'être un peu plus carré et après
réflexion il est nommé java ses passages
à basse et la prévisibilité voilà le
côté explosif voulait dire que quand
vous avez commencé ou pensez pas que ça
se vende riez des disques encore moins
que celle duré dix ans non je n'ai pas
de plan de carrière on n'avait pas de
plan de carrière mais on avait quand
même une major à l'époque on est dans la
baie signer chez sony music dont il y
avait quand même envie de rentrer dans
ce monde de l'industrie musicale voilà
c'est la curiosité en vue de construire
quelque chose
après on sait jamais où ce jusqu'au quoi
vous êtes séparés au bout de dix ans
parce que c'est ça faisait un petit
moment ça va aller tourner beaucoup de
moments
les uns sur les autres c'est il ya pis
moi j'en ai tous comme on dirait
complexe dans le sens avec beaucoup
d'influencé dans vie différente et java
ça prenait énormément d'énergie donc un
moment donné il faut un peu séparé les
atomes et puis pour faire entrer de
l'air et faire autre chose on va
regarder à d'extrait de cheveux bar qui
arrivent au dernier clip hier 5 le
moment vous allez nous séparer
[Rires]
tiens soutient-elle mis un style bien
l'accent bien sûr parisien royal au t2
chien chute le boulevard certes hibbard
placement du comptoir mcadams et mon
terroir bien sûr mon cauchemar
[Musique]
deux matchs à la bombe à l'envers
oubliée je te la fais à la mondiale
à opale par les enfants du bon dieu pour
des canards sauvages fait mon
réquisitoire car chaque flux berges et
claquer le beignet trégueux la tâche que
la marmite flottent sur le rhône
toute cette misère elle mange à la soupe
populaire c'est désert des tartares de
laval star départ tard et quinta soudan
qui vont sortir du tiroir
pour
[Musique]
m
mais tout comme un polichinelle nature
[Musique]
le maire
tous ces cas sont retrouvés pour le
pouvoir
java c'est donc reformé en 2020 pour son
vingtième anniversaire
pas de bol en 2020 c'était l'année du
corps d'un virus est ce que vous vous
êtes retrouvé exactement comme vous
étiez quitté dix ans auparavant ou
est-ce qu'il ya tellement de choses qui
ont changé depuis mais musicalement que
il a fallu se réadapter les uns aux
autres non pas vraiment se réadapter
mais je pense que l'on a gardé vraiment
on est revenu à l'essence même c'est ce
que je disais tout à l'heure de jamal
l'improvisation et le côté imprévisible
et puis le côté explosif aussi mais on a
je pense qu'on est tous on a affiné
notre notre
présence et notre singularité chacun
donc on est nous sommes les mêmes mais
en pire en pire et en plus précis plus
fort voilà donc ya pas de pas de
problème de réadaptation c'est votre
public vous êtes en tournée depuis à peu
près le mois de juin l'adresse terminer
le 7 décembre à l'elysée montmartre
enfin ce cabinet provisoirement voulait
pas décidé de vous quitter après les
versions complètes l'année prochain
combat là et est-ce que public a changé
lui alors ça dépend il ya des festivals
où les gens nous connaissent pas du tout
ce que c'est beaucoup plus jeunes mais
parfois c'était le carré mais hier au
grand soufflet beaucoup de gens de
l'époque mais avec leurs enfants
[Rires]
merci fixes et donc rendez-vous l elysée
montmartre ne le 7 décembre
[Musique]
hélios azoulay vous êtes musicien mais
c'est un roman que vous publié aux
éditions du rocher juste avant
d'éteindre et voici l'image que vous
avez choisi pour notre époque
alors celle là il faut me l'expliquer aa
c'est sont deux enfants ouais dans un
manège à la foire parce que je trouve
que là la vie c'est la foire je trouve
que ça va aussi vite que la chouette oui
mais voilà ça dépend évidemment de
l'état d'esprit à quel moment vous
saisit dans la journée que tout le monde
dans quel type de manège vous vous
trouvez mais je trouve que là il ya des
couleurs absolument sublime et moi qui
me font beaucoup de bien et puis c'est
vrai tous cas une espèce de
véritables tintamarre là-dedans
incroyable dans notre époque et et en
même temps un tintamarre de 2,2 de
l'infiniment en périssables vous
comprenez ce que je veux dire on n'en
finit plus de parler et de tourner
autour de deux choses qui sont et de
paroles ou des cris qui sont mort nés et
je trouve que cette fois ci on arrive à
la saisir avec le sens du burlesque de
la couleur et du manège ça donne quand
même quelque chose parce qu'elle est
assez désirable fin quand on voit cette
image on se dit que oui on a connu ça
enfants et c'est chouette absolument
mais vous avez raison il se trouve qu'il
ya oui on a envie de ces on envie de les
manger toutes ses couleurs ouais
d'accord et au compost une vision de
notre époque et de la vie plutôt
sympathique même absolument écouter
toute façon c'est bien la seule qu'on a
notre disposition je suis a prévenu
ankara tente toujours plein
alors juste avant d'éteindre votre roman
c'est l'histoire d'un musicien juif
d'europe centrale pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale qui se retrouve enfermé
par les allemands dans un ghetto avant
d'être déportés il ya encore des choses
à dire sur cette période surtout quand
on ne l'a pas vécue
je crois peut-être qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de choses à dire qu'on imagine en
tout cas parce que nous avons
naturellement - se sont arrêtés un bien
triste privilège de l'avoir vécu cette
période là alors oui il ya les chairs
extérieur celles et ceux qui l'ont vécu
moi ce sont mes chers l'intérieur qui
parle je crois que je suis et je ne me
l'expliqué très très mal aujourd'hui
mais je suis habité par ce terrible ne
histoire je n'arrive pas en dénouer tous
les drames et j'essaie de peut-être
parfois d'ailleurs dans le roman avec du
burlesque du rire de la rage de la
colère j'essaie d'y injecter quelque
chose de gc ca n'est pas un hommage en
tout cas ce que je veux dire c'est que
je crois que écrit un livre ou faire un
hommage pour enterrer nos matches
précédents ce serait tellement triste
j'essaye le plus possible d'injecter de
la vie dans cette affaire là et
peut-être que pour agiter de la vib il
faut être ambitieux et donc donc oui on
a encore de nouvelles choses à dire je
le crois il ya quelque chose qu'on ne
dit pas c'est pourquoi c'est le mobile
de ce crime épouvantable riz que l'on ne
cesse de ressasser bien sûr n'a été
commis dont on ne cesse d'écrire de
penser de réfléchir
mais le mobile rien qu'est-ce qui a fait
que le peuple allemand s'est acharné à
ce point sur le peuple juif et pas
seulement en allemagne partout où il a
pu là même mettre la main de rim
j'avais posé la question à claude dans
ce match mais on ne doit pas se poser
cette question là cette question là pour
lui était interdite on va interdit c'est
pas le mot dix pensaient qu'elles
n'avaient pas lieu d'être vous êtes
d'accord avec lui
peut-être qui s'est défendu cette
manière là parce que mettre la main sur
une réponse possible je pense que c'est
impensable
ce que je vois moi je vais vous dire
quelque chose c'est que dans une
certaine mesure je rapproche beaucoup
mais mes amis mes frères si vous voulez
tsiganes manouches gitans du peuple juif
qui sont deux peuples qui malgré le fait
d'avoir été piétinées tout au long de
leur histoire je dirais ce sont parmi
les peuples et plus emmerdé de
l'histoire de l'humanité ils se sont
toujours réveiller et notamment avec la
grâce d'un violon et spa vous voyez ce
que je veux dire et la grâce de rester
un peuple cultivé brillant d'hydra et je
crois qu'il a quelque chose pour un
certain nombre de jambes d'insoutenables
alors pourquoi à ce moment là les
allemands etc vous vous rendez compte
tout ce qu'il faudrait la dénouer un
entrelacs un faisable en finlande et le
feu s'éteint faisable je ne peux pas je
serais pas d'accord avec lens mal dans
ce sens où je pense que oui vous pouvez
si vous voulez poser la question de
pourquoi vous l'interdire ensuite trouvé
noël comme moi qui l'avais voilà
gardiennage là mais la trouver une
réponse maintenant si on passait
peut-être deux trois ans ensemble on
arriverait à toucher le bout de quelque
chose mais là je peux pas vraiment comme
vous esquissez dont elle pourquoi mais
le comment je vous cite un vous écrivez
dans ce livre c'est votre personnage qui
parle nous les juifs si on est là
aujourd'hui donc ils parlent d'eux mêmes
ce ghetto où il arrive très mal traités
c'est parce que toute l'allemagne ne
fait que son métier parce que derrière
tout homme qui ne fait que son métier il
y à un nazi oui c'est vrai je crois que
ce qu'il dit en tout cas je le partage
pour cette époque là je crois qu'il y a
tout d'abord il continue d'abord il n'ya
qu'un seul métier c'est le métier
d'homme
c'est vrai
hitler n'a pas de sang sur les mains il
a du sang plein la bouche hitler c'est
le grand dépotoir de tous les silences
yeux de tous ceux qui laissent faire de
tout ce qui signe un papier de ça vous
voyez c'est tout ça que dit ce
personnage à ce moment là oh oui je
crois que je crois qu'à ce moment là il
n'a pas tort au delà du métier qu'on
fait eh ben il ya le métier d'homme et
c'est peut-être ce que n'ont pas oublié
heureusement un certain nombre de gens
mais ce cas oublier la majorité d'un
peuple moi je comprends que les que les
juifs ressasse le g2 site que les noirs
ressasse les esclavages les que les
arabes ressasse la colonisation à ce que
je me dis que si j'étais eux je ferai
sans doute pareil c'est tout à fait
humain ce que je me demande c'est est-ce
que ça sert à quelque chose
vous avez ce aaa
c'est une
là pour eux c'est une question
intéressante à quoi ça sert
déjà je dois vous avouer que si je fais
ce travail là et vous savez notamment
que je joue les musiques composées dans
les tendres je sais qu'il est pour vous
le disais juste un roman voilà ce n'est
pas juste un roman exactement
vous avez raison je crois que
si je fais ça aujourd'hui il me semble
sans pouvoir me l'expliquer c'est qu'il
ya quelque chose en moi qui déborde et
qui me déborde mais que je n'avais pas
imaginé
quinze ans je vous parlais tout à
l'heure de meschers intérieure mais je
ne sais pas de qui de quoi elles sont
peuplées je ne sais pas qui crie là
dedans je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
pourquoi j'en suis là mais ce que je
sais réellement c'est que pour moi il ne
s'agit pas simplement de raconter une
histoire de plus et bien la raconter
au contraire c'est à nice que j'écris
comme j'ai pu d'ailleurs c'est ce que
pardonnez moi mais je crois que un grand
écrivain c'est quelqu'un qui écrit comme
il peut c'est pas quelqu'un qui écrit
bien ça il ya des grandes écoles pour
bien écrire mais je crois finalement
tout s'est toutes ces histoires qui oui
kim a big immeuble c'est par elles sont
sorties notamment dans ce livre là
est-ce que ça sert à quelque chose je
crois que est ce que vous pensez qu'on
peut se poser la question dès lors qu'on
imagine faire quelque chose de grand
voilà moi qui ai peut-être l'orgueil de
dans les concerts que je donne et dans
ce livre de de marquer je sais pas mme
un point de plus dans cette affaire là
je serai pas le dernier a traité ni le
premier vous l'avait bien dit tout à
l'heure
eh bien je crois qu'on peux pas
l'envisager si on se posait la question
de savoir est ce que ça sert à quelque
chose est-ce que ça sert même à quelque
chose pour soi même est ce que l'on se
porte mieux est ce que l'on se dé des
livres de quelque chose excellente
question chez à frédéric alors là je ne
sais pas
alors ce que je sais c'est qu'il y a
quand même
c'est assez curieux dans les concerts
comme dans les livres il ya qu on a
quand même l'impression d'être sur une
montgolfière et de jeter un sac de plus
élevé voilà après ceux qui sont sous la
mangue en faire et qui freinent 5 sur la
tranche 7 l'autre problème mais je sais
pas si je vais mieux mais je ne sais pas
si je laissais tout ça on suspend voyez
ce que je veux dire en ébullition dans
mon corps je sais pas si je me porterait
mieux donc je dois le faire qu'est ce
que voulez vous c'est le portrait d'un
musicien dans l'impossibilité de
composer oui pourquoi eh bien vous savez
depuis plus de dix ans que je joue les
musiques dans les camps et que donc je
ne sais si les musiques composées
pardonnez moi soyons plus précis avec
l'ensemble que je dirige je joue la
musique composée par les déportés dans
les camps bon des musiques plus ou moins
clandestine et c'est bon je me rends
compte que depuis dix ans jure la phase
de bon public il faut jouer ses
musiciens il faut se jouer ses musiciens
et que j'essaye de réparer quelque chose
en écrivant ce livre je me suis rendu
compte qu'en écrivant le destin d'un
compositeur qui lui n'a plus la force
mentale morale
d'écrire mais que j'avais oublié au
moins un destin qui était le destin d'un
musicien qui a pas envie d'écrire qui
lui n'est pas encore dans les camps et
voilà il est dans un ghetto absolument
mais qui n'a pas la force d'écrire et je
crois que c'est une espèce de deux
pareils mais presque de réparation fait
je viens contre pointer ou mettra un
contrepoids si vous voulez à tout le
travail que je fais sur celles et ceux
qui ont composé non helios tu avais
oublié cet homme-là ben oui celui qui a
pas envie d'écrire pour toujours à
jamais la musique parce que lui là bas
il n'avait pas envie de faire de la
musique c'est un temps et c'est un luxe
qu'il n'avait pas envie de se payer et
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas sauf parce que
il par ailleurs il a un peu comme le
garçon qu'on voit sur la pochette oui il
a des leurs bouts de papier il écrit des
mots tout à fait raconter ses mots mais
il aurait pu écrire des notes et ne le
fait pas absolument c'est à dire qu'ils
décident de se
séparer il bon si vous en renonçant pour
aller plus vite à la musique il se jette
dans la littérature mais en fait la
littérature c'est à dire qu'ils notent
ses sensations ses sensations morale
comme ses sensations physiques ce qu'il
appelle d'ailleurs le journal de mes
yeux il prend des petits bouts papier se
remplit les poches de ces petits bouts
de papier et il note tout ce qui lui
tout ce qui traversent son regard comme
ça comme comme tu as vu un appareil
photo il aurait pris des photos sans
aucun doute mais en tout cas il fait ça
comme ça
ça c'est très curieux vous savez parce
que je me rends compte que
autant ce roman est naturellement
extérieur à ma destinée à mon passé et à
mon présent mais ne vient on met enfin à
mon passé en tout cas mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que curieusement on est
vite rattrapé par soi même dans une
fiction dans cet homme qui renonce à la
composition pour se jeter dans
l'écriture je me vois moi et je le
comprends maintenant je me vois moi
lorsque j'arrête d'écrire de la musique
pour me jeter dans l'écriture d'un roman
ou d'un poème par exemple et je crois
que c'est un mécanisme finalement que je
connais je renonce à la pour m'agripper
à l'autre c'est vous je pense qui dit à
un moment où qui lui fait dire à propos
de wagner je rappelle était le
compositeur préféré d'hitler vous dites
on n'aime pas wagner parce que ces
grands on venait mme wagner parce que
c'est gros oui ah
mais c'est vrai je pense que c'est à un
tel degré d'accumulation si vous voulez
que wagner s'effondre sur vous mais je
peux vous savez si on devait faire le
parallèle aujourd'hui avec un certain
type d'art contemporain je pense qu'il
ya des gens qui se retrouvent devant
l'art contemporain et devant cette masse
financière que ça représente et bien non
il sait pas qu'ils sont il apte à juger
c'est que le jugement leur est interdit
il faut dire que wagner quand ça sort à
loïc c'est extrêmement moderne
complètement c'est révolutionnaire dit
tout à fait tout à fait mais moi j'ai
l'impression que oui mais ça lutter et
je crois moussaoui et baudelaire vénéré
wagner notamment bon et bien sûr ce
n'était pas seul tous les musiciens ou
une période wagnérienne avant de se
rendre compte quand même que c'était 1-1
supportable alors vous allez me dire que
c'est un tout petit peu facile mais je
crois qu'il ya chez wagner au delà de
l'oeuvre il y a un projet est le
personnage le dit moi quand j'entends
wagner j'entends pas sa musique
j'entends son projet voilà et moi c'est
le projet wagnérien qui dégoûte mon
personnage juste avant des tables c'est
signé hélios azoulay ça vient de
paraître aux éditions du rocher merci
ait lieu merci à autre la guyane je
voulais signaler et 4 lecture
exceptionnelle de votre livre d'ailleurs
au théâtre de la contrescarpe le 30
octobre le 1 et le 2 novembre et le 18
décembre vous allez vraiment lire tous
les livres non non pas du tout juste des
départs justement je laisse le soin le
genre de pouvoir par petites bouchées
s'appropria un texte se déversent pas
tout merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]